que Gilles plâtré élu au premier tour à
Chalon-sur-Saône et défaite donc de
Christophe cyrug défaite surprise de
Christophe cirrhugues bonsoir Gilles
plâtré grande satisfaction pour vous et
pour votre camp politique ce soir
on sait Christophe sirug vice-président
de l'Assemblée nationale est très
identifié politiquement est-ce que de
votre point de vue ça a joué un rôle
dans cette élection est-ce que l'idée de
votre sanction elle était accentuée
parce que Christophe cyruck est
quelqu'un qui a une dimension nationale
dans ce mandat politique
je néglige pas le fait que ça pue
effectivement jouer mais je crois que
vraiment que la situation de la ville
avec les enjeux forts qui sont les siens
avec des problèmes d'emploi de
circulation qui qui touche et qui impact
fortement la ville quotidienne des
habitants a été ont été vraiment central
sans trop dans cette dans cette affaire
il est évident que les thématiques
locales ont eu un pas largement plus
grand que les thématiques nationales à
Chalon-sur-Saône aujourd'hui
1983 la ville de Chalon était prise par
Dominique Perben 83 c'était c'est ce
qu'on donne en exemple comme le vote
sanction dans une période intermédiaire
vous faites votre Chalon aujourd'hui
aussi un moment symbole en 2014
en 1983 j'avais 10 ans donc
effectivement une nouvelle génération
arrive en responsabilité à
Chalon-sur-Saône je suis pas seul dans
cette affaire vous savez que nous avons
conduit cette campagne à trois avec
Isabelle Dechaux mais Sébastien Martin
je crois que la dynamique que nous avons
créé nous trois les équipes qui nous ont
suivi les Chalonnais qui ont adhéré à
notre projet et d'une amie forte qui
doit aujourd'hui continuer parce que
notre objectif majeur c'est évidemment
de redresser Chalon de la remplacer dans
la Bourgogne comme la deuxième ville
qu'elle doit être à l'échelle régionale
et c'est tout le sens du travail que
nous allons mener à Chalon et je
l'espère bien au Grand Chalon également